euh il nous a été demandé donc de nous
intéresser essentiellement enfin
exclusivement au majeur et donc euh nous
avons analysé à partir des des données
que que les service statistiques du
ministère de la Justice nous a
communiqué la nature des peines qui
avaient été prononcées pour C euh pour
euh pour ceux qui avaient été donc jugés
euh à cette date-là euh je dirais que
sans surprise euh 60 % d'entre eux
avaient été condamnés à une peine
d'emprisonnement ferme euh par
définition euh ils ont été jugés selon
des procédures dites rapides soit de
comparition immédiate soit euh de
comparitiontion sur reconnaissance
préalable de culpabilité euh sur des
ferments
euh et parmi ces peines d'emprisonnement
ferme qui ont été
prononcé un peu plus de la moitié ont
été immédiatement incarcérés euh pour
les autres euh 20 % ont bénéficier d'un
aménagement de peine à l'audience et euh
pour les autres ces peines euh dans
prisonnement ferme euh donc ils ont été
condamnés devant un juge de
l'application des peines en vue
d'examiner les modalités de cet
aménagement euh la quantum moyen de ces
peines d'emprisonnement était de 9 mois
ce qui est inférieur à la moyenne je
dirit annuel constaté qui est qui est de
de 12 mois sachant néanmoins que les
juridictions correctionnelles sont
appelées à juger aussi des faits
euh punis de de de de peine supérieur
comme des trafics de de de stupéfiants
ou des infractions en bande organisée et
commise aussi sur des périodes beaucoup
plus longues donc je dirais
que cette indication est un relativisé
concernant les peines d'emprisonnement
ferme et des incarcétion immédiates là
encore la proportion est plus élevée que
la moyenne mais je dirais que le champ
de comparaison le champ des infractions
que que nous avons pris en compte est
très atypique puisqu'il ne tient
absolument pas compte je dirais des
autres infractions
jugés selon des modes de poursuite plus
classiques ou plus longs
euh par par les tribunaux